foreign
how can we help today
all right so yeah I'm 24 years old
um you know my whole life I was told to
buy a home and now that I'm of age to do
so for myself my wife you know have a
baby on the way come in January
um I'm just scratching my head wondering
if it's even worth it anymore you know
where I live I can't even buy like a
burnt down Shack for 350. so
that's a God's truth uh
well it feels a little hopeless right
now for you uh in your particular
situation and you're feeling the weight
of the responsibility of the new life
that's getting ready to come to you and
you're like holy crap this just got real
exactly yeah so all of that to say
you're you might not be ready to buy a
house today and that's okay when you're
saying your whole life you've been told
you should buy a house but do you want
to buy a house
I do want to buy a house you know the
freedom of owning it is a lot nicer than
you know we have a really good situation
we only pay 1400 a month uh which where
we live is like amazing oh yeah that's a
deal
yeah so I mean I just want to also thank
you guys because of you you know we're
able to pay off thirty thousand dollars
to steal a loan debt uh you know I could
say I'm debt free now so which is
awesome but it's taken a long time to
just you know stash away and it's you
know we're about a year into the process
now good for you probably have another
one well if you don't buy a house for
two years or three years that's fine
that's not the end of the world and
you're in a very expensive market so
it's going to take you getting on top of
the income side of things and getting a
good strong down payment to make it
happen let's pan back from that and say
go back to your original question which
kind of had a hopelessness tone to it
it's like is it even worth it is it even
worth it well yeah it is worth it it's
not worth doing it stupid and it's not
worth you know buying a house you can't
afford and all that kind of stuff and
it's so take your time and do it do it
with wisdom but it's worth it and here's
why two things happen with homeowner
three things happen with home ownership
that make you want to do it as a
long-term play versus renting your whole
life okay number one rents go up every
year
since God was a boy rents go up every
year
I mean I've had my real estate license
since 1978 rents go up every year in
every Market they go up every year they
don't go down
and and every year and so you're gonna
have you know every year more and more
and more your money is going to go out
the door for housing and if you buy a
home and you lock down your payment
your rent doesn't go up anymore
that's run number one number two the
value of the house goes up
and when you were on when you rent
obviously you don't own anything that's
going up number three as we have studied
millionaires ten thousand of them we
find the primary two things that are in
their bucket that allow them to build
their first million to five million
dollars worth of work net worth is their
401K Roth IRA retirement plan in good
mutual funds like we teach and a paid
for house
that has gone up in value and so getting
work to pay that off so it's a great
wealth building tool it stabilizes the
largest line item in your budget which
is housing
and if the largest line item in your
budget is going up every year that sucks
yeah it definitely leaves you vulnerable
but I think in your situation it's kind
of important to separate things out so
you've got your personal situation and
thinking through is this the right
timing for us and then you have you know
the market in the world and everything
like that don't let your situation and
thinking maybe you should wait a year or
two make you start getting negative
about the the market start looking at
news articles start getting hopeless I
mean it's so easy to get drugged down
into those feelings of negativity
especially when the whole news cycle is
talking about how bad real estate is and
how there's not hope for our generation
and you can't buy a house now like don't
let your feelings and fears you know get
wrapped up in what the world is saying
right now if timing for you is bad and
the market timing is bad that does not
invalidate a lifetime of real estate
ownership
the to your point those are different
things separate those out I'll give you
the first two the last one no I won't
give you